So now that we have our potion implemented
in the fashion that we want
So now that our potion is implementing
implemented so now that are potion
is implemented in the function in the way
the function in the
So now that our potion is implemented into
our project
In the fashion that we want in the fashion
what am I supposed to say
I'm just going to say it Blaine excuse me
wow
So now that our potion is implemented into
our project how we want it to be let's go
ahead and add some extra Flair
So when I draw my health now I wanted to
show some
crossbones actually instead of just zero
when my health is actually zero
So how we can do that instead of just having
equals hero Health here
We can open this up using our back takes
like we talked about earlierAnd this will
give us access to string interpolation.
And inside of thisI'm going to actually
create this a.
Curlies around itAnd add this dollar sign
now since I've added the curly brackets and
it's.
dollar sign I can also use JavaScript
functionality within this these curly
brackets
So from here I can say when hero.health is
greater than zero
I'm going to use a ternary to say the first
So I'm going to use a ternary to say if
hero.health is greater than zero if that is
true
I want you to just assign hero.health or
excuse me that's the only wayHero.health
here.
But we'll use this colon here to separate if
that's not true let's actually use a skull
and crossbone again
And we'll put three of them there
So what's going on here with this ternaryIs
this is going to be my condition.
Just like in a conditional for an if
statement we provide a condition so it's
actually two
YeahMy if statement is is if hero DOT health
is greater than zero.
And then we have this ternaryAnd this is
due.
She will let's give a one cuz I do want to
give a little space hereFor this and we'll
say.
If it's zero doIf true.
Then we'll add someElse.
If Falls
So essentially ifThe heroes health is
greater than zero.
Return just return Heroes healthElse.
Return triple crossbones
And that is essentially what a ternary is
cuz the other use case of a ternaries you
always want to return something out of it
And that's why we actually didn't use a
ternary down hereWe use the double Anderson
to just return.
Essentially if this is trueBecause right
here I didn't have anything to return if it
was false so we would use a double Amber
stands for that.
So let's go down and do the same exact thing
for this villain's healthUnless go ahead and
copy it.
And let's just change his heroWe'll just
highlight hero double click it hit that
control d.
And we'll just type in them there as well
AwesomeSo at this point let's go to our web
application.
UnlessAnd let's see if we can get those
crossbones up into the sweet I found a
health potion.
So if you don't actually want to go through
this right now like if you're trying to test
this out what you can do is go to your
devtools here
And I can actually say hero.healthEquals.
Zero.
So the next time I attack it's going to say
he's dead awesome I get my triple crossbones
as well
I found a health potionAnd I can't drink if
you're dead sweet.
So let's also check the same for my
villainSo we can actually dive into.
That villain object and we'll just say
villain's Health equals one so we can see it
happen live
Awesome we vanquished themTook a little bit
of damage but now we can see the villain
health is indeed dead as well perfect.